-♪ Sentence Sneak ♪
♪ Sentence, sentence ♪
-Now, here's how it works.
We'll each get cards
with sentences written on them.
These sentences
are completely random.
All right?
-Uh-huh.
-Our goal is to work these
sentences into a conversation
as casually
and seamlessly as possible.
Here are your cards.
Here are mine.
Now let's let
the sentence sneak begin.
-One at a time?
-Yep.
You look at the first card.
Now, I'll just say, what do you
love most about the Fall?
-Uh, I like, you know,
going out on hikes
as the leaves are falling
and hearing, you know,
the lovely crunch
underneath my feet,
and I've got quite big feet,
so I've got quite a big crunch,
and in that way, I've got
a lot in common with Bigfoot.
[ Ding! ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Both laugh ]
-Whereas he likes the Fall?
Is that what you're saying?
He enjoys the animals?
-Well, you know,
because he's got big feet,
and so I imagine,
when Bigfoot's walking around,
the Sasquatch, he's gonna --
you're gonna hear
the crinkle and the crackle
of his big hairy feet.
-Crinkle and crackle.
-My feet aren't that hairy,
but they are big.
Yeah.
-Yeah.
Yeah. And he goes around and --
-He just mooches around.
-I don't think --
I think that he --
that he lives in a house.
-Do you think he lives outside?
Do you like the outside?
-Yeah.
I love the outside.
I'd love --
You know what I'd love?
I'd love a tent.
In fact,
I once asked Santa Claus
for a tent when I was a child.
I never got it.
[ Audience "Awws" ]
Yeah, I think Santa Claus
owes me a present.
[ Ding! ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-You know,
it's strange, that, isn't it?
Just having
a bit of a beef with, uh...
[ Laughing ]
[ Laughter ]
-With Santa Claus, yeah.
-Oh, with Santa Claus, yeah,
with Father Christmas.
It's just --
Oh, God.
It's just, you know...
[ Laughter ]
You know, it's oftentimes
that things take me back --
[ Laughter ]
-What do you mean?
Like getting
in a fight with Santa?
-Getting in fight with Santa.
Or you know, it's just whenever
people complain
about some things.
You know what I mean?
Oh, just sometimes...
Well, for example --
-You can talk to me.
I'm your friend.
-You sure?
-Yeah, tell me anything.
-You know,
it's like they say in Wyoming,
you know...
[ Laughter ]
weathermen are great dancers.
[ Ding! ]
[ Laughter, cheers, applause ]
-I've heard that.
I've seen --
-You've seen them.
-I've seen that uh -- yeah.
-Yeah.
-Yeah. Uh-huh.
-I don't think
that's such a bad thing.
[ Laughter ]
-I think there's --
I think that
should be on a T-shirt.
-I think that
-And I think that T-shirt
should be a slogan,
and I think
that slogan should be famous,
and I think aliens
should be called
Outer Space Boys, you know?
[ Ding! ]
-That's a great name.
You think a lot of things.
-I love to think.
-Thinking -- Thinking is good.
-And it's sometimes
when you don't think,
that really
exciting things happen.
You know, just things
that are left to chance.
You know sometimes when you --
For example, you know,
when you've got
your phone in your pocket,
and you just accidentally
kind of butt-dial somebody.
I mean, once, I actually
butt-dialed Michael Phelps,
and it changed my life.
[ Ding! ]
-How?
How so?
[ Laughter and applause ]
-How --
It changed your life?
Why?
Did he pick up the phone?
-Well, before, I used to take in
a lot of water when I swam,
and now --
-Yeah.
-Until you almost drowned.
-I almost drowned.
Yeah.
-I love swimming.
I love any --
-What's not to love about
swimming and Michael?
-No, I love swimming.
I love the --
the hats and the goggles
and the --
-Yeah.
-...Speedos.
-The Speedos.
-Get me in a Speedo and --
Get me near a Speedo, and I
break my camera out immediately.
-Do you?
-Yeah.
-Do other people do that?
I mean, do you have
to do that in private,
or is that not a problem?
[ Laughter ]
-People want it from me.
People -- People --
People want it from me.
-We all want you
in your Speedos.
-No. Well, it's for --
Obviously.
39 people subscribe
to my fashion blog.
[ Ding! ]
So they all want to see.
-[ Laughing ]
-39 people.
-Almost 40 people.
My mother's not into it, yeah.
-I'm glad I don't have a blog.
Otherwise, you know...
I find, you know,
the thing I'd probably get into
on a blog would be cooking.
I like cooking, as always.
-I hate to interrupt your story.
-Please, tell me.
-Would you mind
singing something for us?
-Sure.
-I mean, just -- we'd love --
-Just something?
-We enjoy your singing.
-I know a song.
What is this one?
There's this cool song called
"I Dropped It."
And it goes
a little something like this.
[ Laughter ]
-Could we dim the lights?
♪ It was late ♪
[ Laughter ]
♪ I was cooking ♪
♪ And everything's going fine ♪
♪ I got my masher out
to mash my potato ♪
♪ And then it took
a funny turn ♪
♪ Couldn't quite get
the mash mashed ♪
♪ Inside the pan on the stove ♪
♪ So I stretched out
like I was tired ♪
♪ And that's when it happened,
lo and behold ♪
♪ I got mash in my trousers ♪
[ Ding! ]
♪ Yeah ♪
-Oh, yeah!
I love it!
-♪ Dropped right in there ♪
-That was the greatest
smooth conversation.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Every time.
Everybody does something silly.
-So good.
-Benedict Cumberbatch
right there.